تقدم منصه قوى الرقميه التابعه لوزاره
الموارد البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه اكثر
من 130 خدمه يستفيد منها كافه اطراف سوق
العمل حيث تهدف الى اتمته سوق العمل
السعودي وزياده الشفافيه والوضوح وحفظ
حقوق اطراف العلاقه ليصبح اكثر جاذبيه
للاعمال واسقطاب الاستثمارات
وتعمل قوى على اعاده هندسه اجراءات
الخدمات المقدمه في سوق العمل وتطويرها في
منذ لحظه تاسيس الاعمال تقوم منصه قوى
بدعم المنشاه حتى مرحله التوسع عبر تقديم
العدد الذي تحتاجه من التاشيرات ورصيد
النقل من فتره سماح لمده عام كامل من
برنامج التوطين نطاقات
وتنقسم الخدمات المقدمه الى المنشات الى
خدمات تتم بشكل فوري مثل خدمات التاشيرات
المهنيه واصدار وتجديد رخص العمل ولوائح
تنظيميه وكذلك اصدار شهاده السعوده كما
تتضمن خدمات المؤسسات عبر منصه قوى خدمه
المستشار الالكترونيه لاصحاب الاعمال
والتي من خلالها يتم عرض عدد من المؤشرات
الحيويه التي تهمه صاحب المنشاه
وخدمه التقارير الشهريه مع الرؤساء
التنفيذيين واعضاء مجلس اداره الشركات كما
تتضمنوا خدمه التنبيهات الاستفاقيه
المساعده في التخطيط وازاله اي عقبات تحول
دون نجاح الاعمال
ومن اهم مزايا من الصديق وايضا اشراق
الموظف في كل التعاملات التي تتعلق بحياته
المهنيه وامكانيه الاطلاع على السجل
والمؤهلات الوظيفيه ويمكن للموظف اضافه
الدورات التدريبيه ومشاركه الملف الوظيفي
عبر رابط خاص ومعرفه حقوقه الماليه
المستحقه واحتساب مكافاه نهايه الخدمه عبر
ادوات وحاسبه رقميه الجدير بالذكر ان منصه
قوى هي المنصه المعتمده لتوثيق العقود
الوظيفيه للموظفين السعوديين والمقيمين
حيث تم نقل الخدمه اليها من المؤسسه
العامه للتامينه الاجتماعيه خلال العام
الماضي 20 اثنين وعشرين
[موسيقى]